BUT FIRST, THOSE WHO BET AGAINST
AMERICA, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT’S "ANGLE."
WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE HERE AT
THEY SHORT THE MARKET.
THEY SHORT THE DOLLAR, AND WHEN
THINGS LOOK UNFAVORABLE AND THE
SITUATION GETS A LITTLE ROCKY AT
HOME, THEY LOOK FOR THE EXIT.
MAYBE THEY MOVE THEIR MONEY OR
BUSINESSES OFFSHORE BECAUSE THEY
THINK AMERICA HAS SEEN HER BEST
DAY.
ABOUT TRULY SMART PEOPLE,
INCLUDING SMART DEMOCRATS, KNOW
THAT BETTING AGAINST AMERICA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A LOSING
PROPOSITION, EVEN DURING OUR
DARKEST HOUR.
THE CIVIL WAR, THE
GREAT DEPRESSION.
AT A RECENT BROOKSHIRE MEETING,
WARREN BUFFETT WHO IS NO FAN OF
DONALD TRUMP DISCUSSED AMERICA’S
PAST AND FUTURE TRIAL.
>> YOU HAVE THIS TESTING PERIOD
AND PEOPLE REALLY, THEY HAVE
LOST FAITH TO SOME DEGREE.
THEY JUST DIDN’T SEE THE
POTENTIAL OF WHAT AMERICA COULD
DO.
AND NOTHING TO STOP AMERICA WHEN
YOU GET RIGHT DOWN TO IT.
AND THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND IT
MAY BE TESTED NOW TO SOME
DEGREE.
BUT IN THE END, THE ANSWERS
NEVER BET AGAINST AMERICA.
>> Laura: AND IT SHOULDN’T
SURPRISE YOU, ANY OF YOU, THAT
WARREN BUFFETT IS A HELL OF A
LOT SMARTER THAN LEFT-WING
ECONOMISTS WHO HAVE BEEN
PREDICTING DOOMSDAY SCENARIOS
FOR THE U.S. ECONOMY SENSE
COVID.
WELL, TODAY THE DOW JONES JUMPED
500 POINTS ALMOST CLOSING ABOUT
20,000.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE ACROSS THE
BOARD ARE SEEING -- AND IN
TEXAS, GEORGIA, SOUTH CAROLINA,
UTAH, FLORIDA, ALABAMA,
MISSISSIPPI, ALL RAN BY PRETTY
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNORS, WELL YOU
SEE LIFE IS FINALLY GETTING BACK
TO NORMAL.
EVEN CALIFORNIA’S LOCKDOWN GAVIN
NEWSOM IS UNDER PRESSURE FROM
LAWSUITS, BUSINESS OWNERS AND
PEOPLE IN THE FAITH COMMUNITY,
AND HE HAS HAD TO EASE UP ALSO.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICIALS
INITIALLY SUGGESTED THE LOCKDOWN
CAN LAST THROUGH THE SUMMER.
BUT AFTER MASSIVE BACKLASH
ACROSS THE BOARD, L.A. COUNTY IS
AIMING TO REOPEN ON JULY 4TH.
AND CHURCHES ARE OPENING AT 25%
CAPACITY STARTING TOMORROW.
AND AS FOR THOSE GOVERNORS WHO
WANT TO JUST ACCEPT YES FOR AN
ANSWER, DON’T BELIEVE FOR A
SECOND PAIR FRAUDULENT
JUSTIFICATION THAT IT’S ALL FOR
YOUR OWN SAFETY.
YOU KNOW, THEY ALWAYS SAY THAT
WHEN THEY ARE TAKING AWAY YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
BUT IT IS BECOMING MORE OBVIOUS
BY THE DAY THAT THESE
POWER-HUNGRY GOVERNORS AND
RADICAL MAYORS ARE ENDANGERING
THE STATE’S FUTURE AND WILL
EVENTUALLY SEE THE STATES LEFT
BEHIND.
NOW, ISN’T IT ENOUGH
ANDREW CUOMO CREATED DEATH TRAPS
IN NEW YORK’S ELDERLY
FACILITIES?
BUT NOW HIS SLOW ROLL TO REOPEN
IS DOING UNTOLD DAMAGE TO HIS
STATE GOING FORWARD.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WROTE THIS
PIECE OVER THE WEEKEND.
THEY RAN IT HOW THE COVID SHUT
DOWN HAS BEEN THE STRAW THAT
BROKE THE CAMEL’S BACK FOR
NEW YORK.
MORE RESIDENTS NOW ARE REPORTING
BEING SO FED UP WITH LIFE IN THE
BIG APPLE THAT THEY ARE
RELOCATING TO PLACES WHERE THEY
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A DECENT
STANDARD OF LIVING.
AND CUOMO WANTS TAXPAYERS IN
FLORIDA AND TEXAS BEYOND TO BAIL
HIM OUT?
NONE OF THESE LOCKDOWN LIBERALS
SHOULD GET A PENNY MORE IN
BAILOUT MONEY SO LONG AS WE
CONTINUE THIS LOCKDOWN STUFF
BECAUSE THE LONGER THEY STAYED
LOCKDOWN AND YOU HAVE ALL THESE
OTHER ONEROUS AND UNNECESSARY
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE, THE MORE
DIFFICULT, THE MORE EXPENSIVE
AND I WOULD SAY THE MORE
DANGEROUS IT BECOMES FOR THEIR
STATE THE LONGER IN A RECOVERY
BE.
GIVEN THAT WE KNOW THE VIRUS IS
A LOT LESS DEADLY THAN WE
THOUGHT AND ITS MOST DANGEROUS
TO THE COMBINED ELDERLY?
THERE IS NO GOOD REASON TO KEEP
ANY PART OF THE COUNTRY
COMPLETELY CLOSED.
UNLESS THAT IS, YOU DON’T WANT
AMERICA TO RECOVER AT LEAST 12
TRUMP’S PRESIDENT.
AN ARTICLE IN POLITICO YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD IT, IT REPORTED
DEMOCRATS ARE PRIVATELY FREAKING
OUT, YES, YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
THAT THE AMERICAN ECONOMY WILL
BE IN MASSIVE RECOVERY IN THE
FALL.
CHECK THIS OUT.
MY BIG WORRY SAID FORMER OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL WHO IS SO
CLOSE TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ASKED ABOUT THE LEVEL OF CONCERN
AMONG TOP PARTY OFFICIALS.
HE SAID IT IS HIGH, HIGH, HIGH,
HIDE.
NOW HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE THIS
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT DEMOCRATS SEE
THEIR ONLY SERIOUS PATH TO
VICTORY HINGING ON YOUR DESPAIR?
DEEP DOWN, IT SEEMS LIKE THEY
ARE ROOTING AGAINST LIFE GETTING
BETTER FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES.
THEY ARE ROOTING FOR AMERICANS
TO REMAIN UNEMPLOYED?
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT FROM ANYONE
OR FOR SCHOOLS TO STAY CLOSED?
WELL, NOT LONG AFTER WE FLATTEN
THE CURVE THEY ISSUED THESE GRIM
WARNINGS OF A SECOND WAVE, A
THIRD WAVE THAT CAN COME NEXT
MONTH AND COME IN SEPTEMBER.
IT COULD BE WORSE, I MEAN, OR
THE SUPER-SPREADER PHENOMENON
YOU HAVE TO HAVE 18 FEET SOCIAL
DISTANCING OR 30 FEET OR FEET
SPREAD 40 FEET.
EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY DAY YOU
HAVE TO PUSH THE PANIC BUTTON TO
SCARE YOU BACK IN YOUR HOME.
THEY SHAME PEOPLE WHO DON’T BOW
DOWN TO THEIR NEW RULES.
BUT IN THE END, MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE SEEKING TO CONTROL YOUR
BEHAVIOR DON’T APPLY THE RULES
TO THEMSELVES.
THEY NEVER DO, DO THEY.
WE WILL SHARE THE BIGGEST
OFFENDERS WITH YOU IN A MOMENT.
NOW WHAT WORRIES THESE
HYPOCRITES IS NOT THE DIRE
SITUATION THEY CREATED IN THEIR
OWN STATES, THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF YOUR
SAFE, ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
TRUMP COULD BE POISED TO BENEFIT
FROM THE DRAMATIC NUMBERS
PRODUCED DURING THE PARTIAL
REBOUND PHASE THAT WILL COINCIDE
WITH THE FOUR MONTHS BEFORE
NOVEMBER.
THAT HAS MANY DEMOCRATS SPOOKED.
NOW, LET THAT SINK IN FOR A
MOMENT.
WHERE YOU AND I ARE SPOOKED
ABOUT THE IDEA OF LIVING LIKE
MASS ZOMBIES WAITING FOR
GOVERNMENT CHIPPED THE MIC
CHECKS FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SPOOKED BY THE
IDEA -- THAT IN MARCH, BIDEN’S
CAMPAIGN, PELOSI AND THE WHOLE
GANG BETTING THAT THE VIRUS
WOULD CRIPPLE THE ECONOMY RIGHT
THROUGH THE ELECTION.
THE ONLY WAY THAT THAT HAPPENS
NOW THOUGH IS IF ENOUGH BLUE
STATE GOVERNORS MAKE LIFE
UNLIVABLE FOR THE 99.99% OF
AMERICANS WHO SURVIVED THE
VIRUS.
THAT IS A PATHETIC ANTISCIENCE
SICKO CAMPAIGN STRATEGY.
BUT LET THEM MAKE THAT BET.